vamos a practicar la solución de
ecuaciones que involucran fracciones y
decimales tenemos esta ecuación
obviamente involucra fracciones es menos
un tercio igual a jota entre cuatro
menos diez tercios los invito a que
pausa en el vídeo y tratan de despejar
jota para que se cumpla esta ecuación
hagamos esto juntos a mí me gusta dejar
sola en un lado la variable que quiero
despejar y como la tengo del lado
derecho vamos a pasar todo lo demás al
lado izquierdo quiero quitar este menos
y éste cios y esto lo puedo hacer
sumando diez tercios en ambos lados de
la ecuación pues si lo hago en un solo
lado ya no se conservaría la igualdad lo
que hago en un lado también lo tengo que
hacer en el otro lado
sumó diez tercios en ambos lados de la
ecuación
del lado izquierdo tengo menos un tercio
más diez tercios nos da nueve tercios y
esto va a ser igual a menos y es tercios
más y es tercios se cancelan y nos queda
jota entre cuatro
este nueve tercios es igual a tres lo
que simplifica un poco esto lo
reescribimos tres es igual a jota entre
cuatro
ahora para despejar j tenemos que
multiplicar ambos lados por 4 si tengo 4
que divide a algo y multiplicó por 4 ese
algo pues me quedara solo ese algo si
comienzo con jota que está dividido
entre 4 y luego lo multiplicó por 4 me
quedara jota solita en el lado derecho
pero si multiplique por cuatro el lado
derecho también tengo que multiplicar
por cuatro el lado izquierdo lo hacemos
y nos queda 4 por 3 12 jota por 4
dividido entre 4 nos queda jota tenemos
que jota es igual a 2 lo genial de las
ecuaciones es que podemos verificar que
efectivamente tuvimos la respuesta
correcta si sustituimos el 12 en lugar
de la j
tenemos que menos un tercio es igual a
dos cuartos menos diez tercios
cómo funciona esto doce cuartos es igual
a tres y si queremos tener esto en
tercios tendremos nueve tercios y nueve
tercios menos diez tercios nos da menos
un tercio que es correcto
hagamos otro ejemplo
n entre 5 + 0.6 igualados vamos a dejar
solo en el lado izquierdo el término que
tiene a la n quitando este 0.6 restamos
0.6 en el lado izquierdo pero no podemos
hacerlo solo en este lado también
tenemos que hacerlo del lado derecho
para que se mantenga la igualdad del
lado izquierdo nos queda en entre 5 y
del lado derecho tenemos 2 menos 0.6 que
nos da 1.4 si no quieren hacer esta
operación mental la pueden escribir si
fuera mental sería 2.0 menos 0.6 es
decir que hay 20 décimas menos 6 décimas
que nos da 14 décimas que es lo que
tenemos aquí o usamos el método
tradicional de tratar de restar seis del
cero reagrupamos y nos queda 10 porque
tomamos un uno prestado del 2 y nos
queda 1
décimas menos seis décimas nos da cuatro
y alguno que tenemos le restamos 0 nos
queda 1 que es 1.4 y ahora para despejar
n tenemos del lado izquierdo n entre 5
así que necesitamos multiplicar por 5 5
x entre 5 nos da n pero no puedo
multiplicar por 5 solamente el lado
izquierdo también tengo que multiplicar
por cinco el lado derecho
nos queda en e igual a 1.4 por 5 y si no
quieren hacer esta operación mental la
podemos escribir esto es 1 en 2 quintos
por lo que todo esto es igual a 7 pero
podemos calcularlo también así 5 por 4
es 20 reagrupamos el 25 por 15 más dos
es 7 y al ver los números que
multiplicamos vemos que hay un dígito a
la derecha del punto decimal por lo que
mi respuesta tiene un dígito a la
derecha del punto decimal también 7.0 o
simplemente 7 n es igual a 7 y podemos
verificar esta respuesta sustituyendo el
7 en lugar de la n 7 dividido entre 50.6
es igual a 2 hagamos otro ejemplo porque
es bastante divertido
tenemos 0.5 que multiplica a todo esto r
2.75 y todo esto es igual a 3
hay muchas formas de resolver esto
muchas veces al ver algo así nos vemos
tentados en distribuir este 0.5 aquí y
acá pero esto nos complicaría un poco
los cálculos aunque si lo hacemos bien
llegaremos a la respuesta correcta pero
algo más sencillo sería dividir ambos
lados
entre 0.5 y así me quedaré con más
números enteros recuerden que lo que
hacemos del lado izquierdo también
tenemos que hacerlo del lado derecho y
esto lo hago para deshacerme de este 0.5
de la izquierda y si divido el lado
derecho entre 0.5 voy a tener un entero
3 dividido entre 0.5 es lo mismo que
dividir 3 entre un medio cuántos medios
hay en 366 medios hay en 3 estos se
cancelan y acá nos queda 6
simplificando nos da r + 2.75 igual a 6
y para dejar sola a la erre del lado
izquierdo restamos 2.75 de este lado
y como hemos visto varias veces no puedo
hacer esto en un solo lado también tengo
que hacerlo en el lado derecho
esto se simplifica como r igual
cuanto 6 2.75 si quieren hacer el
cálculo mental
6 - 2 sería 4 y si a este le restamos
0.75 no os queda 3.25 si no quieren
hacer el cálculo mental lo escribimos
6.00 menos 2.75 y tengan cuidado de
alinear bien los decimales y reagrupamos
0 menos 5 centésimas no lo podemos hacer
tratamos de reagrupar acá pero tampoco
podemos así que tendremos que reagrupar
desde acá tomemos una de estas unidades
y nos quedan cinco unidades la unidad
que tome serán diez décimas y voy a
tomar una de estas décimas y nos van a
quedar nueve décimas y aquí tendremos
diez centésimas ahora sí podemos restar
diez centésimas menos cinco centésimas
nos da cinco centésimas
décimas siete décimas nos da dos décimas
y cinco menos dos nos da tres 3.25 y
pueden verificar estos tres puntos 25
más 2.75 nos da 6 y al multiplicar la
por punto 5 nos da tres así que
nuevamente tenemos la respuesta correcta